okay there it is we've spotted some
debris it looks like several logs here
might have come off the rock wall and
we'll scoop that right into the debris
nay we follow the contours to the bottom
of the bay and we use GPS and a chart
plotter to do that you can see my track
has been on a point where there's been
20 feet of water and 40 feet of water
and the currents will move in a
different speed less creating a tie
drift or tide line which is where the
debris gathers even though I can't see
the debris I know where the Tigers are
we pull out over 1,200 tons of debris
every year some days we'll have 50 to 60
tons in one day some days we'll just
have five times some of the largest
things we picked up is a hundred and
thirty foot tree also we picked up a
concrete houseboat foundation right in
the middle of the shipping lane it was
about 40 tons by itself all concrete and
floating
one year there was reported about 12
dead whales in the bay and I think we
ended up moving or towing about four of
them this pier log is typical one of the
piles they put into the bay throughout
the expansion back in the 40s is soaked
with creosote a creosote is tremendously
bad for the environment and these are
pretty good hazards to navigation some
of them are 10 15 20 people on some have
metal spikes in them and it can rip into
a fiberglass Hall we take it to our
disposal yard we cut it up till it fits
in the right bins and we haul it to an
appropriate landfill that takes care of
hazardous waste the whole boat has been
upgraded with new engines and this was
the first Army Corps boat that runs a
hundred percent biodiesel the crane is
actually 64 years old so we have found
parts on ebay when it's working we don't
fix it the San Francisco district has 22
federal ship channels that we maintain
along a 600-mile coastline of central
and northern california this is a big
bag we try to cover during a week the
whole entire Bay it's a recurring
mission and it's something that we do
year in and year out for the most part
at the other day we feel real good about
the job we did
you